Winchester Mystery House in San Jose
California is one of the most haunted
places in America Winchester Mystery
House is a incredibly unique Victorian
mansion created by Sarah Winchester
heiress to the Winchester Repeating Arms
fortune Sarah Winchester had a series of
unfortunate things happened to her
including the death of her husband and
daughter she was a spiritualist and
visited a medium to try and understand
why the medium said well the gun the one
the West there's a lot of Carmen there
so head west and build a house to
appease these spirits she started
construction in 1884 which didn't stop
until the day she died the house is 160
room Victorian mansion is no master plan
there's a lot of strange attributes
there's 40 staircases 40 fireplaces four
elevators we have a number of staircases
that lead right to the ceiling doors
that open up into nothing or it's just a
wall the house is known for its spirits
who many people believe are the ghosts
of people who worked at the house or
even Sarah herself a lot of our guests
and employees have had very strange
things happen to them
this house sometimes it's just footsteps
hearing a voice the life that flickers
or sometimes it's an actual full
physical manifestation if we haven't
solved the mysteries in 93 years then I
don't know if we ever
[Music]